[Music]
i really rap two in stores right now
october dirtier
money look let bygones be bygones
fo fire fire like dilon if the shoe fit
this ain't the one to try on
duke you'll be running out them kicks
like zion i hustled on the strip [ __ ]
die on
[ __ ] on a [ __ ] [ __ ] iron taking
business trips with no tie on
from the same street dumping dimes dubs
and now my [ __ ] rolling thirties like
i'm davey's
labels ain't wanna touch em now i'm
bubblin like turkey bacon in the oven
i mean buzzin like my older blood cousin
on the second six like a dozen
see more cake stack bundles i can see
your face rest in peace pop smoke
[ __ ] do your fake at the table and i
see our plates
ain't nothing on them no biggie it's a
[ __ ] warning
hey that thunder knows [ __ ] storming
no i ain't no killer b but we be [ __ ]
swarming
and these hoes ain't got nothin on them
i'm a pimp you should see how i be
nuttin on them
god son like big fred pull up in the
culinary same color as big red
see you out here struggling to see me
smother with big bread while y'all i
hate cuddling chicks that's kissing my
[ __ ]
[ __ ] pay attention put that bread on
the pension
all i see is red no you dead for
redemption yeah
you come at fred for attention i'll be
at your neck like i lynched them
holler let you boy
[Music]
look i murder lyrics i got a phone with
3 500 verses in it
flow dirty like it got a lot of curses
in it i opened surgery to body like a
surgeon did it
under 30 minutes not under 30 minutes
but under 30 minutes as soon as the
verse is finished
don't have to take you to a chapel he
won't get the liberty for playing with
the statue
play me like a raffle i scrape your
little rascals stock hide and tesla
aiming at your apple that's a snapple
this [ __ ] is factual but you ain't in my
class no more because i passed
you i will trash you you little trash
you
put the garbage in the trash you who
want to add q
i got a bar for all you rad flukes i was
part of the hardest rap group out rap
pool this is grade a
since the 8th grade they've been calling
me a legend we're the same age
until society is regular i'm aiming at
his head like i'm trying to get his
temperature
black cars riding like the senator ten
of us not a sign of my competitors
i ain't regular a guard lyrically etc
hearty [ __ ] i need an enema register i'm
beyond raw
you better calm yours i'm on another
level you on the wrong floor
i don't see the rookies i don't spot the
flunkies i just keep it hoodie you know
kind of funky
out in l.a trying to look like i am not
a junkie with them bags of cookies like
i got the munchies
i don't know why you would hate on me at
all for i want all my sons to make it
i'm the ball ball you all talk all your
[ __ ] corning you're a cornball and you
ain't rich enough to be bowling
you're a poor sport poor sporter i'm
flexing in the oricon
northward couldn't question what i do to
songs i only click with the realest
y'all be super drawn just to take a
picture with [ __ ] to get your groupie
on
i'm about to go and spin a squirrel on
these louboutins you iceberg head ass
[ __ ]
get your goofy on hurry up and make your
point you done copy copy i'm with this
famous joint trying to duck the
paparazzi
damn they like tummy on some real [ __ ]
how the hell you out here getting better
and you still sick
still lit had punches forever and they
still hit y'all she know i get these
kids together it's a field trip
but on some real [ __ ] i don't even got
nobody left to keep it real with they be
on some chill [ __ ] i be on some kill
[ __ ] beretta and it's weighing heavy on
me like a guilt trip
weighing on me like it's guilt from new
york so for the sport i came and scoring
like i'm will
all this talking get you killed keep it
taller keep it real you don't miss me
with the bull i turn your jaw
[Music]
who you really think you control you
ain't remotely close just know i'm ready
for the body and i'm off parole
it's back to testing everybody like the
mori show bro
i'm looking like the goat out here i
blow your brains out you really ain't
got no idea i'm on the same route
[ __ ] moving slow out here you think
it's snowed out here it's really cold
out here
be clear i still got them nice things
texting
every time i rap they hit me right king
yes king y'all look dumb trying to x
what i've been
flexing yellow my sons pick one right
wing left wing writer